نامل ان تتخذوا قرارات ايجابيه بمدنا
بطائرات اف 16 وغيرها من الاسلحه الفاعله
بامكانكم مساعدتنا على تحقيق الانتصار
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
والدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا يجتمعون في
المانيا في وقت تترقب منهم كلاب قرارا
حاسما بشان امدادها بالدبابات وقد طلبت
منهم طائرات اف 16 لاول مره والمانيا تربط
تزويد اوكرانيا بدباباتي بما سمته اتفاق
الحلفاء في حين قال الكريم ان الغربه واهم
بشان تحقيق النصر
الجيش الصومالي يعلن صده هجوم لحركه
الشباب على قاعده عسكريه في مدينه جل العد
وسط البلاد ومقتل سبعه من جنوده و مئه من
مسلحي الحركات بينما تحدثت الحركه عن
عشرات القتلى في صفوف الجيش والحاق اضرار
كبيره بعتده العسكري جوجل تنضم لركبي
عمالقه التكنولوجيا في تخفيض العمل وتعلن
عزمها تسريحه ثني 10,000 موظفا بسبب تراجع
والدتها الماديه تقارير رجحت اسباب تسريح
شركات التكنولوجيا اعدادا كبيره من موظفها
الى تضخم كوادرها خلال فتره كورونا نظرا
للطلب المتزايد على خدماتها
المنتخب العراقي
يتوج بلقب خليجي 25 بعد تغلبه المثير على
نظيره العماني بثلاثه اهداف الاثنين في
المباراه النهائيه التي امتدت الى شوطين
اضافيين وبذلك يكون اسود الرافدين قد
حققوا لقبهم الرابع في البطوله التي اقيمت
على ارضهم هذه المره
[موسيقى]